finally the day has arrived where I can
finally say I have reached the end of
Naruto I have completed this series I
started this blind review with
absolutely no idea how this story would
progress our pan out and today I will be
giving my Impressions and review for the
finale to this series as well as my
thoughts on my experience overall this
is the last video I have planned for now
concerning the Naruto Series so for the
last time for quite some time sit back
grab your headbands and let's bring this
one home I'm totally not Mark and these
are my first impressions of thoughts on
and review for the ending to Naruto
[Music]
foreign
I'll be making on Naruto 4 and as of yet
undetermined amount of time I think what
might be cool since I have exactly six
volumes of manga left to read and review
I'll break up my review into six parts
each one representing a singular volume
capping off with my overall thoughts at
the end so let's dive in oh wait ah
heads up I am writing these individual
volume reviews as I read them meaning as
I write and give my immediate
Impressions on say volume 69 I will be
doing so with no information as to how
volume 70 and Beyond will progress cool
cool volume 67 to say that I was hyped
to return to this story would be an
understatement while the arc itself was
extremely long and boring in parts
around the middle by the time the final
pieces started falling into place around
65 to 70 of the way through the arc
everything sort of clicked I found
myself feverishly ingesting volume after
volume until I had to stop for fear of
writing a video that was way too long
Naruto has been a terrific story however
not one without moments I felt it's slip
in terms of holding my interest this is
normal however now that I'm on what
feels like the home stretch I can't
imagine this manga ends in any other way
than satisfying in my mind Kishimoto has
already done the hard part he's after
creating a broad and complicated World
filled with nuanced characters each with
their own justifications cultures that
back those ideologies and stories the
legwork and Exposition necessary to
believably create these interactions has
already been done and he's even managed
to bring all of these characters
together for a conclusion I am immensely
happy with in other words so far I'm
loving it the cover of this volume sees
Naruto teaming up with his father this
section deals with a lot of interesting
strategies I had a great time with for
instance last week we went from bad to
worse as Obito became something entirely
different channeling the strength of the
ten-tailed Beast and due to this we have
virtually no idea what this individual
is capable of and so when the strongest
and most experienced on the battlefield
the former Hokage chose to use
themselves as resurrect capable Pawns in
order to analyze the strengths and
movements of this target albino all of
admit that I kind of geeked out a bit it
was a great idea and this volume is
filled with moments to geek out or get
excited over Sasuke getting the team up
with Naruto is one that I found
fantastically enjoyable with Kishimoto
demonstrating this fact as the fight
progressed through interesting layouts
and Page spreads and okay at this point
with Sasuke I'm still getting the
feeling that this isn't so much a
reconciliation but more so a temporary
Alliance given the nature of this
occasion but hey I gotta take what I can
get Kishimoto utilizes a lot of natural
tension building techniques here also to
help escalate the scope of the battle
and the consequences associated with it
my favorite being his decision to Grant
obedo the power to effectively nullify
the edotensei which translates to that
sequence we got to enjoy with the former
Hokage now cannot be performed without
consequence rip Naruto's dad's arm I
guess and speaking of Minato I think my
favorite part about this volume and what
it tries to do can be seen through
kishimoto's decision in how he depicts
minato's internal monologue as it
happens failure is a word Minato uses a
lot in this Arc and indeed this volume
throughout this story from the beginning
through to this moment Minato has been a
character spoken of extremely highly
he's touted as being virtuous Noble
powerful heroic a savior much like
hashirama despite only being recently
deceased the deification of his
character by The Village he worked for
is abundantly clear and yet Kishimoto
feels it important in this moment let us
know that even someone like he can feel
like a failure and the same is true for
hashirama the way these characters have
been built up as Gods over the entire
series for this Arc to humanize them has
been incredibly effective for its themes
and messaging we as an audience are made
to feel the full spectrum of negative
emotions both hashirama and Minato feel
for what they have failed to do and
prevent during their tenure as Hokage
feeling responsible for all of this
happening and by association the
destruction of the area and its people
and I like this because as we are placed
into the shoes of this one-time Godlike
figure through his eyes we get to see
the Magnificent answer to all of these
worries and questions in his son Naruto
oh also the fact that Naruto and Kurama
were able to make use of the other half
of the fox inside Minato made sense
surprised me and made for some awesome
moments and shots I mean overall this
volume was great there's a tremendous
amount to love in it and it continues
the great climax I prayed so much last
week in natural ways and what's more is
the next volume is even better volume
68. during this section I couldn't help
but draw my own mental parallels between
Naruto and hashirama and indeed Sasuke
and Madara forcing me to contemplate
questions like will history repeat
itself is Sasuke going to become madra
in this generation well not if Naruto
has anything to say about it this Arc is
enjoying quite a lot of payoff for sure
however what ties this complex web of
conflict cause and effect together is
Naruto and the Infectious Spirit he
inspires his team with there's this
scene with Shikamaru and I swear it gave
me chills to see this dude go from
someone I hardly noticed early on due to
his inactivity and lack of desire to get
involved transforming because of Naruto
into this next level tactician ready to
pick himself up to contribute despite
him virtually having no energy was so
damn uplifting and in this instance it's
all down to Naruto
this quote from nine tails for me
touches ever so slightly and one of the
most significant pillars of Naruto's
character and one that I think is not
only essential to this battle but indeed
the entire story this is a battle that
sees Sasuke his friends and indeed now
these beat you all side with Naruto to
Rally with him in one last final effort
to try and take down Obito to stop his
Pursuits in performing the infinite
tsukoyomi to save the world I'm not sure
if this is a prominent talking point
people discuss in this fandom but I have
heard some folks talk about Naruto
having an unfair Advantage compared to
others in the story that the fact that
he has had this Bijou inside of him has
offered him a unique privilege perhaps
an unfair one thus detracting from how
some people might feel about Naruto and
while I can see where they're coming
from with the fox providing him a near
Unlimited Supply of chakra and healing
Factor thus leading to a lot of his
success in the story I think if you came
away from this tale with that Outlook it
feels at least to me reading at this
point in the story that you might have
missed the entire point of of this
section and indeed a core part of
Naruto's character development as this
Series has progressed there's no secret
that this story particularly in this
moment is trying to glorify the
attributes in virtue's Naruto's
brandishing however something that's
important to remember is that a central
through line of this Arc and story has
been that very easily Naruto could have
turned out exactly like Obito too which
is why obedo is seen trying to reach or
corrupt Naruto at every turn in this Arc
but more broadly understanding this I
think is intrinsic to understanding and
indeed appreciating Naruto as a
character it's why he shows empathy
towards practically everyone and wants
to reach them if he thinks that they can
be reasoned with Gara is the first great
example of this that I can think of
someone that was so close to becoming a
psychotic monster thanks to who Naruto
is not his Bijou but because of the
decisions Naruto made Gara was able to
be saved and the same has been true
countless times in this story it's
demonstrated time and again that the fox
Spirit could very easily have led to
Naruto's downfall both in a literal and
philosophy sense numerous times the
deciding factor wasn't the gift or curse
he was bestowed or burdened with by his
father but the perspective he looked at
the world through in other words Naruto
is where he is because of who he is not
what he has as many have pointed out
both in this battle and in the past
Naruto as a person is someone people
want to trust in to chase after and an
individual that brings out the very best
in everything
the conversation between Obito and
Naruto speaks to this reality this
philosophy that being altruistic honest
and everything else Naruto is is what
ultimately makes him successful in what
he sets out to do in this moment obedo
acknowledges that he has the same will
and body as the sage of Six Paths his
jinchariki was the most powerful all of
this is true but in the same way all of
Naruto's Powers don't make him who he is
the power and potential isn't what's
important in this instance it's who you
are that ultimately determines what you
are speaking on a sort of mechanical
sense given that Obito was a sympathetic
villain and a Fallen Hero I thought this
was a great way to cap off his
contribution to the story as an
antagonist the paneling by Kishimoto
employing a lot of white space was
fantastic in illustrating the difference
between Naruto and obedo specifically
with Naruto surrounded by people his
comrades his friends people he's
inspired and uplifted to stand by him
and Obito standing on his own and
furthermore this whole sequence was an
apt chance to shift Focus from him to
uchiya Madara further amplifying his
fall from where he was all that time ago
volume 69. okay so the hype level is at
10. obedo has been reached but he's been
abused and used by moderate to bring him
back to life we're in the end game here
we go one thing I'll give Kishimoto
credit for in this Arc is that this
absolutely feels like the final battle
of a series it feels massive with each
choice made either having massive
ramifications or creating snapshots in
time that I'll definitely remember like
all the tail beasts joining forces to
take down Madura for instance that said
I need to draw attention to something
small but also that's kind of irritated
me for a while matara looks like he's in
bad shape after that attack and
rightfully so he just got a building
dropped on him effectively he lost his
arm and all that jazz and then this dude
shows up gives him a hand literally and
then Madara pops an eyeball into his
skull like it was nothing now I haven't
said anything about about this in the
series before but why is it that
everyone in Naruto seems to be able to
pop in eyeballs into their skulls like
Lego I mean there's a host of things
that need to surgically connect and
happen back there I'm willing to accept
that ninja magic is real in this world
but I draw the line there apparently but
I digress stuff does happen in this
volume a whole lot of stuff a little
while ago in this Arc I complain that
certain characters weren't used more
throughout this story like Gara for
instance was an example of a character
in Prior videos that I've made however
I'm thrilled that he's going to play
quite a central role in this story with
this moment here bringing his character
full circle into a hit kishimano does
utilize the last minute flashback trick
he loves to pull out but it hasn't been
used for a hot second and this was
really really good getting to see the
one-tailed Beast thoughts on Gara and
his history with humans was interesting
and gained to see Gara do everything in
his power to try and protect someone he
sees as an equal was wonderful and
ultimately heartbreaking when they all
eventually fall to matara including
Kurama ripped from Nara toe for the
first time in this story Naruto doesn't
have the foxtail spirit inside of him
anymore something that he would have
wished and begged for at the beginning
of this story is now something that is
both tragic and a major blow to both him
and everyone around him now that's
character development
following the tens Cliffhanger of a
chapter that touted both Sasuke and
Naruto taken completely out of
commission and on the verge of death I
have to say that I was in near disbelief
with wakishimoto managed to do with the
story after this now I say disbelief not
because it didn't make sense but because
it did I'm always so interested and
impressed when a story that's so long
and winding manages to take all the
broad story components that make it so
and tie everything together neatly at
the end and this scene dealing with this
drama does this in Spades it left me
with chills hype and above all else
emotionally devastated in ways I never
thought this story could leave me the
story of Kakashi and Obito has been one
that has Alert in the background of this
manga for quite some time slowly we've
seen their respective backstories how
Kakashi received the eye how Obito lost
his way and through struggle we're now
seeing him come back into becoming
himself it's honestly difficult to
concisely disclose my feelings on this
section so I'll just bounce off this
quote those who lead others never step
over their comrades corpses even if
their own ends up being stepped on I
adore literally everything about this
quote from the dire circumstances
leading up to it to the one delivering
the line to who they're delivering the
line to and what that means in the
broader context of the story this is
Obito's Best Line in the entire series
and another shunning example of how
brilliantly thought out and well
conceived of and crafted by Kishimoto
this climactic battle was there are
callbacks to the unification of Kakashi
and Obito which draws us back to quotes
that allude to their power being greater
together than separated it really makes
for a fantastic coming full circle for
the character of Obito himself in ways
that make him more interesting than most
I've come across in this story one that
takes a naive but virtuous character
throws him down a disillusionment path
and through run-ins with the main
protagonist of this story learns to find
his way back to the light that he once
abandoned which speaks to this quote he
shares with Naruto as he's trying to
help him later he says I've never been
able to walk a straight line but I've
finally gotten to where I needed to go
the entire story felt so fulfilling
cathartic and worthwhile I mean it when
I say that this part of the story was
hitting me exactly as Kishimoto wanted
me to experience it and broadly the same
happens with Sasuke albeit not due to
his direct input but instead his
brothers leading to Kabuto fulfilling
the place of Obito in Naruto's situation
the entire scenario is just so well
conceived of and performed that I'm
honestly thrilled with how everything is
going so much so the next part took me
entirely and completely off guard
volume 70. Guy versus Modera I know I'm
the guy online that repeatedly says
things that are the best or that such
and such thing is my favorite of all
time Etc I'm a pretty energetic person
and when something excites me in a story
I honestly get overcome with enthusiasm
and energy because of this when I'm
reviewing a story I need to express my
enjoyment of a particular choice I tend
to use hyperbolic statements when I
can't conceive of an effective way to
convey just how wonderfully a particular
scene or character has made me as a
reader feel however in hindsight I think
what started as an innocent exclamation
of adulation has become a crutch for me
to burden with the load of translating
my enthusiasm to you all as listeners
Guy versus Madara is a scene that does
not deserve such treatment it does not
deserve a shortcut it deserves my best
because this fight scene right here
moved and connected to me in ways that
no other part of this story has managed
to achieve and due to that I want to
take my time to explain why I am 30
years old and being 30 is weird you're
not really old yet it but you're also
not really young either and coming to
terms with that second part has really
[ __ ] with me ever since turning 30. it
sounds redundant to say this but you
spend your whole life being young and a
kid until one day you're not and there
was a moment where I thought to myself
how do I not be a kid chasing a dream or
goal should I change should I stay the
same a lot of popular media details
Coming of Age stories where the naive
hero grows to become a well-rounded
adult in the context of the story but
once they become the adult normally the
story ends so does my story end here is
everything after this boring what's next
well I think how Naruto answers this
very question is not only profound but
resonated with me in such a resounding
fashion I simply need to share my
experience I've spoken at length in
Prior videos concerning my appreciation
for kishimoto's tackling of the themes
of fostering the Next Generation through
characters like Naruto and Shikamaru
recognizing they need to adopt more
responsibility as they transition into
to the new part of their lives but it's
guy's message that hits me like a ton of
bricks and that message is to find
meaning not in yourself but in what you
can leave behind for others Naruto's
greatest message for me Isn't when it
Embraces traditionally shown in stories
about overcoming your limits or
achieving your dreams with your friends
but ironically when it flirts with what
lies beyond your typical Shonen Coming
of Age Tales when I turned 30 I had a
crisis for my entire life I was always
in a phase where I was working towards
something for me to grow up into
something that could contribute
something meaningful but once I got
there I didn't know what else to do
other than coast and stare vacantly into
the void that was the rest of my life
apparently okay okay that's a little
dramatic but it's real and that's why
guy's Journey has been so impactful for
me I've never been the best at anything
in my life and to this day I still hold
that fact to be true I'm not the best
writer the best speaker debater reader
reviewer boss YouTuber brother son or
even husband but I want to be I love to
work hard and I try never to dwell on
the scrutiny of other people when they
review my content react to it or even
misrepresent it everyone and I mean
everyone is entitled to feel however
which way they want about me and my job
is to focus on what it is that I can
control and when I read pretty much the
exact same philosophy come out through
guys flashback my hands started to shake
and I paid closer attention I'm serious
as I watched this man after a life of
people belittling both him his father
and his pupil for their differences and
approach and ability to see him not only
motivate himself but find profound
meaning and resolve in the fostering of
the Next Generation and doing quite
literally everything in his power to
ensure that they have their chance to do
the same in the future for their future
Generations is a watershed moment for me
with this series guy by virtue of him
being the most human character has
delivered the most impact in this series
for me gorgeously depicted by Kishimoto
in these moments as he opened was the
eighth and final gate for what he knows
will be his last time guy charges
forward unflinching and not looking back
knowing that he'll never return again
because what he achieves in his life is
not measured by himself but by the
successes of those who have been
impacted and loved by him
broadly speaking Naruto and Sasuke are
the result of this world's Heroes
Warriors like Kakashi guy Asuma shikaku
iruka and countless others have
attempted to Foster the best attitude
possible out of them and in this same
breath we learned that Obito and the
Darkness he wrought onto the world was a
direct result of moderous manipulations
and the opposite philosophy Madara in
this instance highlights what happens
when one can't find meaning in the lives
of others and the Next Generation
striving instead to do everything he can
for himself by himself and towards his
own goals with everything else including
his family friends and future
Generations acting as necessary damages
for him to reach his desired outcome I
have no idea what sort of entities
Naruto and Sasuke have become but what I
do love about it is the manner with
which you were basking in this
Monumental yet daunting moment Kakashi
reflecting on the seeds he's helped to
set long ago not taking credit but
honoring to be there alongside them
nevertheless whenever they need him team
seven is readying for a battle to save
the world Kakashi reminded them of their
very first lesson the importance of
teamwork and just oh it's so good okay
so as things were ramping up and the
story felt as though it was heading into
the end game I decided to just binge the
remaining manga so here are my reactions
to that the infinite tsukiyomi once
Madara activates it and entrances
everyone on Earth more than lives up to
its premise I thought the visuals
accompanying this are striking and
horrifying watching those people are
mummified while hanging like cocoons
from the branches of this satanic tree
was nothing short of brilliant to watch
however shortly after something happens
something I know a lot of you have been
waiting for me to talk about
kaguya you have at first a quick word
from our sponsor
did you know April is National
testicular cancer awareness month one
man every hour every day is diagnosed
with it it's one of the most common
forms of cancer in men between the ages
of 15 and 35 and that's why I'm proud to
be promoting manscape's partnership with
the testicular cancer society today
cancers unfortunately something I've had
several experiences with my grandparents
died of cancer and earlier last year my
own father had a serious brush with it
it's now something I have to keep a
close eye on with regards to my own
health and I'd encourage you all to do
the same manscapes donating fifty
thousand dollars to the testicular
cancer society this year and as part of
this they're really encouraging you to
work checking yourself into your
manscaping routine I mean it makes sense
right you've heard me talk many times
about how awesome the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer is being waterproof and cordless
is obviously great but that led light is
the key here it really helps you to get
a good look at what's going on down
there and honestly it's just a great
piece of Kit so please make checking
yourself a priority today pick up the
lawnmower 4.0 and head to manscape.com
forward slash TCS to learn more about
how to perform simple self checks at
home to prevent testicular cancer as
always using not Mark 20 will get you 20
off plus free shipping so head over to
manscape.com and take care of your pair
you know talking about this I realized
is going to be a lose-lose if I like it
people will hate me for it and if I
dislike it people will also hate me for
it but why do I say this I've spent the
last number of years catching up on a
number of series I've neglected to start
in the past some of the most popular in
the world like one piece JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure and Hunter Hunter but out of
all of these Naruto seems to be the
story that has conversations surrounding
it filled with more love and hatred than
anything I've covered prior Naruto's
original run took place around the same
time the majority of people around the
world started routinely using the
internet and in addition to that was
also released around the same time as
other popular series like bleach and one
piece together the three properties
became known as The Big Three despite
not being present in these fandoms
during this time I can only imagine the
level of competitiveness that was
fostered between the various communities
which for a small number of people
perhaps fostered or encouraged some to
attach a portion of their own identity
to their given favorite one piece bleach
or Naruto and while I did get an
impression of this mindset during my
review of one piece I still found that
to be largely positive but when it came
to Naruto not just with my videos but in
unrelated conversations beneath tweets I
would make I could believe how some of
you guys would treat each other like for
instance I was spoiled intentionally for
my genuine honest attempt to share a
good faith impression of the scene and
creative choice and the only reason I
mentioned any of this is because Naruto
is one of the most enjoyable and
positive series I've read over the last
few years I've enjoyed it more than
Hunter Hunter and even JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure with one piece being the only
one I found to be more engaging
consistently and that's no small feat if
you know how much I loved one piece
Naruto has this profound ability to
toggle my heartstrings while also
boasting one of the most endearing main
characters across the various properties
I've just mentioned it's a story about
cooperation caring for people and
fostering relationships but look I don't
want to belabor this point too much so
let's move on to my overall thoughts on
this scene what did I think of kaguya
despite what I understand Kishimoto to
have done with kaguya as a concept and
final main villain with her for all
intents and purposes philosophically and
literally embodying the root of all
suffering in the main plot so to speak
and despite the terrific metaphor with
Madara literally being consumed by the
darkness he's embraced and brought to
the world despite those upsides I didn't
find kaguya to be an engaging final
villain up until the revealer for in
this story kishimono had quite
masterfully I thought managed to tie
every relevant piece of information and
respective character together to form
catharsis bombs that honestly made this
very long final fight so much snappier
than it otherwise would have been
without and an important component
within that for me was familiarity with
these characters for me Naruto was very
much a character-driven story Kakashi
nobito worked as a conflict in this
section because of their history
together other and the various fights I
complained about earlier in the arc
didn't work for me because I didn't know
them as characters prior I wasn't
familiar with them I had no investment
emotionally and thus had to rely on one
side of conflict to try and carry my
interest yielding a less than Stellar
second act in the Shinobi War Arc in my
mind for me this is what happened with
the climax to this big fight while I was
thrilled with the cooperation and
camaraderie demonstrated with the likes
of Kakashi Sasuke Naruto and Sakura all
coming together for the final struggle
all I could think about was how much
better and more satisfying this would
have been had the target of these
attacks and co-opt efforts being someone
I cared about at all like Modera out of
virtually nowhere El felt as though
Modera as someone that had been built up
across the entire story was abruptly
benched in favor of swapping out someone
I comparatively didn't care for at all
and honestly after that it felt as
though the story sort of forgot him but
does this mean I didn't like the ending
does this mean I didn't love the story
of this monk does this mean that I will
look back on my time with Naruto as a
tainted experience with which I can't
look past the negativity
hell no while this particular choice is
something I didn't personally like or
connect to very much is in no way it
takes from my enjoyment of everything
that came after or before it I hope
something that I've made clear during
this review Series has been just how
much fun I've been having with this
story and what I've Loved about it
unless the entire Narrative of a given
property is built around a singular
moment in time then I find it difficult
to relate to those that say this moment
ruined the story for them in the same
way a good ending doesn't retroactively
make a Bad series good a lackluster
conclusion to a fight doesn't
retroactively make a good series Bad
speaking of someone that loved how
Dragon Ball Super's anime came to an end
I'll also say it doesn't by virtue of
its existence make those boring or
uninspired moments in the middle any
more palatable for me and that's not to
say that this final Conflict didn't have
some killer emotional gut punches either
by the way watching Sakura Sasuke and
Naruto deliver the final blow to kagya
was a terrific moment and Obito's gift
and parting conversation with Kakashi
was spectacular killer way back when I
started the story I would have never
imagined that Kakashi would end up being
one of the most important and Central
characters to this story and that's sort
of what I'm driving at here this wasn't
just a singular isolated moment or
collection of moments it was a long
journey there are 72 volumes in this
series which detail a story of a lonely
child with a dream of one day making
something of himself despite his
detractors and upon that mission
statement this story more than delivers
on that front and speaking of which this
fight's ending despite it not being
something I resonated with it also
wasn't the ending of this story and
funnily enough everything after this
fight offered yet more stuff I did enjoy
Sasuke vs Naruto it's difficult to
disconnect my feelings on this final
Conflict from my feelings on this entire
story again like most aspects of this
finale section of the story it's handled
brilliantly filled with callbacks to
words that have been exchanged between
the two self-admitted best friends with
two diametrically opposed outlooks on
life in more ways than one this felt
like what happens when an Unstoppable
Force leads an immovable object which to
be honest is fitting given the
characters we have in question here with
the anime's rendition of what was
presented in the manga pulling out all
the stops leaving my jaw firmly on the
floor the animation was
spectacular to say however that I didn't
expect this to be the way the series
would round things out would be a lie
however I felt a long time ago that this
would be the best way to end things then
it was it felt a little corny or
simplistic at times particularly after
the complex web of converging plot lines
in the last battle but that could very
easily be to its benefit depending on
your point of view I felt extremely
conflicted during this battle and to be
honest in a good way while I felt like I
knew what the out would be I wasn't
ready to put money on it either the
ending to this fight felt satisfying
albeit a bit extreme given the
motivations involved but then again they
are essentially gods in the bodies of
children so it did make sense in the end
true to his character Naruto once again
proves that he can win over even the
most stubborn of Minds all the while
making good on his longtime promise to
Sakura I would have liked if Sasuke
stayed with the village for a little
longer than he did but I can understand
his mindset for leaving too I guess he's
a complicated guy overall the final
class between Naruto and Sasuke was epic
not in scope but in Impact here we have
the longest rivalry in the story come to
its natural conclusion with an
appropriate level of emotion and
narrative callbacks employed to help tie
it all together which finally after all
this time brings me to the Final Chapter
this is the perfect ending for Naruto in
my mind it's simple it's a mirror image
of the very first chapter and I loved it
the entire story of Naruto itself has
been that of a young man's journey to
achieve achieving his desired goal of
becoming Hokage and so for it to end
with his coronation while showing off
where everyone else is at was hugely
enjoyable getting to see Shikamaru
Hinata choji Ino Sakura and all of the
other Central supporting characters find
their places in the village felt fitting
for sure but it's also only part of what
I loved about this final chapter and
indeed this series at Large
I've touched on this numerous times in
this video and across this series I've
written while this is a story of one
character's Journey it's also a story of
how that one character connects to and
grows alongside others in his life what
they become where they each Find meaning
in their lives and what they ultimately
leave behind and while this Arc did a
fantastic job of showing Naruto's
struggle towards his ultimate goal its
ending also emphasizes another Central
Point to the story that life goes on and
that there's more than just the goals
immediately in front of you alongside
the coming of age heroes we've witnessed
the lives of across this story were also
introduced to the Next Generation the
Next Generation that can only exist when
one fights for and finds meaning in a
tomorrow they might never see to Foster
The Young and to be remembered long
after you've drawn your final breath and
that's such a wonderful sentiment to end
this incredible journey with a beginning
of every one of these 72 volumes that
comprise this story Kishimoto writes a
short paragraph discussing everything
from his struggles to his gratitude to
his milestones and on this final volume
he wrote this this is my final volume
thank you so much for your support these
past 15 years I'd be honored if in the
future you occasionally recall that
there was once a character named Naruto
well then please enjoy the conclusion to
Naruto in my very first videos covering
Naruto I discussed the story behind
Musashi kishimoto's road to eventually
achieving his dream of becoming a
mangaka a story of a young man
struggling to attain his goal in an
incredibly competitive industry
story of a young person who struggled to
get noticed to not be forgotten together
Kishimoto and the character of Naruto
helped each other achieve their
respective dreams a character that was
once incredibly lonely found lasting
friendships and support and a struggling
artist found worldwide Acclaim and
success through his own inspirational
story I can confidently say that for as
long as I live I will neither forget the
story of Naruto or indeed the legend of
Musashi Kishimoto
[Music]
never coming down break into the
contents Never Falling Down
[Music]